- Hello, everyone.
We're gonna get started.
Quick reminder to please
put your headphones on.
Hope everyone is having a great re:Invent.
Welcome to What's new in Amazon Redshift
and Amazon Athena session.
My name is Imran Moin.
I'm a senior manager of product management
within the Amazon Redshift team,
and I'm delighted to have
my co-speakers with me.
Scott Rigney, who is a
principal product manager
with Amazon Athena, and Sean McKibben,
who is a principal software
engineer with Twilio.
In this session today,
I'm gonna kick things off,
talk about what's new in Amazon Redshift.
Then I'm gonna hand it over to Sean,
who will talk about how
Twilio is using Redshift
and Athena to transform
billing and analytics at scale.
And then finally, Scott
will come up on stage
and talk about what's
new in Amazon Athena.
When we look at customer
needs for analytics,
we see that, broadly, things
fall into three main use cases.
On one hand, you have
customers that want to store
and analyze vast amounts
of structured data
from their business systems,
run SQL queries on them,
and get insights on that
data by visualizing it
in BI dashboards like Tableau, QuickSight,
Looker, et cetera.
These use cases are well suited
for a cloud data warehouse.
On the other hand, we have customers
that have vast amount
of raw, unstructured,
or semi-structured data,
and this data is often
used for advanced analytics
or machine learning types of use cases.
These use cases are well
suited for a cloud data lake.
And then you have customers that want
to bring data warehouse
and data lake together.
They want to combine the
structured business data
with the unstructured
or semi-structured data,
so that their teams can work off
of a unified data foundation
and they're able to get richer insights
into all of their available data.
The industry typically refers
to this as a lakehouse.
At AWS, we have built
a portfolio of services
that are geared towards meeting
all these different use cases.
Amazon Redshift is our
purpose-built cloud data warehouse
that provides high
performance SQL analytics
on your structured data.
Amazon Athena is a serverless way
for customers to query their unstructured
or semi-structured data stored in S3,
using a familiar SQL interface.
And then Amazon SageMaker
brings it all together,
where you can analyze
your data warehouse data
and data lake data together in one place,
so that your teams can
get richer insights,
mostly for advanced analytics
and machine learning types of use cases,
and all your teams can work off
of a unified data foundation.
Let's begin with Amazon Redshift.
Amazon Redshift has had
a history of innovation
over the last 12 or 13 years.
When we first launched Redshift in 2013,
it was a first ever cloud data warehouse,
providing massively parallel
processing, columnar storage,
and a familiar SQL interface
at a fraction of the cost
of your traditional on-premises system.
When we launched Redshift
Spectrum in 2017,
customers had a way to
query their data lake data
stored in S3, bridging the
worlds of data warehouse
and data lake together.
More recently in 2022, we
launched support for Zero-ETL,
where you could bring your data
from your operational databases
and business systems
directly into Redshift
without having to worry
about managing complex ingestion pipelines
and data processing workloads.
Last year, we launched AI-driven scaling
and optimization for Redshift Serverless,
where Redshift would
automatically scale up
your compute clusters if
there is a certain spike
in demand or query volumes,
so that you continue to
get the best performance
out of your underlying
Redshift infrastructure.
Along the way, Redshift
has also invested heavily
in optimizing the
performance of your queries,
which is why Redshift has 2.2 times
better price performance
than its nearest competitors,
enabling you to get faster
insights on your data
at a fraction of the cost.
Each of these first
two market capabilities
demonstrate that Redshift
continues to evolve
with the changing customer
needs, which is why, today,
it is used by tens of
thousands of customers globally
for their business critical applications.
It processes billions of queries
and exabytes of data every single day.
As we look at 2025, Amazon
Redshift has delivered a number
of key features and innovations
that can be broadly categorized
into three broad investment pillars.
The first one is cloud data
warehouse fundamentals.
Second one is distributed warehouse,
and the third one is
Apache Iceberg support.
And I'm gonna talk about each
of these three investment areas.
Cloud data warehouse
fundamentals remain at the core
of Amazon Redshift innovation
because they underpin
every customer's trust
and success in the platform.
This includes areas such
as security, performance,
global region availability, et cetera.
Areas that are crucial for
any cloud data warehouse
to work well.
Let's start with performance.
Historically, Amazon
Redshift has invested heavily
in query performance, delivering up
to 2.2x better price performance
than its nearest competitor.
In fact, for specific workloads
such as BI dashboarding,
Redshift actually offers seven times
better price performance
than its nearest competitors,
which is one of the
hallmarks of its leadership
in cloud data warehousing.
This performance is an area
where we continue to invest
and we are not done yet.
You can expect further improvements
from Redshift in 2026 and beyond.
Let me dive into some specific
areas under performance.
First one is materialized views.
Materialized view is an
area of ongoing innovation
for Redshift, where we provide
you pre-computed results,
query results stored in a database
designed to provide you
the best performance
for your commonly used queries.
This year, we have delivered a number
of key capabilities for materialized view.
Starting with in June, we
delivered incremental auto refresh
of materialized views
triggered by DML commits,
where anytime there is a change
in the underlying base tables,
Redshift automatically triggers a refresh
of materialized view.
This provides you with near
real-time updates on your data
without having to go
through manual tuning.
In July, we also release
cascading refreshes
across nested materialized views,
so that you don't have to go
through complete refreshes
every single time.
And in September, we
delivered materialized views
that are built on top of
materialized views on shared data,
providing you the ability to optimize
and pre-compute queries
on shared data sets between clusters.
Each of these advanced
materialized view capabilities
are designed to provide you
with near real time access
and insights into your data
with minimal manual effort.
I'm also happy to share
that in September this year,
we announced general availability
of a feature called
multi-dimensional data layouts,
or MDDL, which is a query
aware sorting mechanisms,
where Redshift automatically
sorts your tables
based on your query
patterns and query volumes.
Unlike fixed column sorting,
MDDL provides up to 10x
better price performance
for selective repetitive queries,
and it far outperforms tables
that are sorted based on single columns.
What's even better is that
once Redshift determines
the right layout for your table,
it automatically applies that layout
using automatic table optimization,
thereby minimizing the amount
of manual tuning you
need to do on your tables
on an ongoing basis.
Security has always been
job zero for Amazon.
It is our highest priority
and it is the foundation
of our customer trust.
This year in January, we
enhanced the security defaults
of Amazon Redshift.
Now your Redshift clusters
are private by default.
They are fully encrypted,
and they require SSL
for every client connections
coming into Redshift.
With these new settings,
it's easy for you to adhere
to the best practices in data protection,
and also minimizes the
chances of misconfiguration
that might happen on your part.
Let's take a look at the
second big investment pillar
for Redshift in 2025, which
is distributed warehouse.
As big enterprise customers continue
to scale their Redshift environment,
we had to reimagine what the future
of cloud data warehouses would look like.
Last year, we outlined a vision,
where customers would have
different analytics workloads,
such as BI dashboarding,
ETL/ELT ingestion,
real-time analytics, et cetera,
where customers would run all
of these different analytics workloads
on their own dedicated clusters optimized
to provide the best performance
for each of those workloads.
All of these clusters also
were designed in such a way
that they can share one common data set.
They could either read or
write to a single copy of data.
This year, we have enhanced
this architecture even more
and added a bunch of new
features and capabilities.
This architecture is available
in two different flavors.
First one is hub and spoke,
where different workloads run
on their dedicated clusters,
but they read and write
from a single copy of data
that is tied to a main
cluster or producer cluster.
The second architecture is
a data mesh architecture,
where each cluster has
its own copy of data,
but it securely shares that data
with all other remote clusters
that might need access to that data.
This distributed warehouse architecture
is designed to provide best performance
for each of your analytics workload.
It provides workload isolation,
and it also provides more
granular cost visibility
and chargeback capabilities
so that enterprise customers
that have different business
units or different teams
can deploy this in a
secure and scalable manner.
Next, I'll talk about
Amazon Redshift Serverless.
Ever since we launched Serverless in 2021,
we have seen many enterprise
customers adopt serverless
for their business critical needs.
This year, we have made
Redshift Serverless
more cost effective, more
flexible, and more easy to use.
In March, we launched
support for trailing tracks,
where customers that
required more stability
and more time to test new releases
before they are deployed in
production are able to do that.
All you have to do is simply
set your serverless clusters
to be on trailing track,
take your time testing those features out,
and when you are ready,
you can deploy those new
versions into production.
We knew that a lot of the
government and federal agencies
required high degree of security
and compliance standards,
so I'm very happy to share
that in May this year,
Redshift Serverless achieved
FedRAMP authorization,
so that your federal
contractors, government agencies,
and regulated industry customers
can now deploy Redshift Serverless
in their production
environment with confidence.
In June this year, we deployed
support for four RPUs,
which is a very small form factor
down from eight RPUs,
which we used to have.
So customers that have smaller workloads
can easily get started
with Redshift Serverless
with lower cost, and
still get the benefits
that serverless offers.
Four RPU costs as little
as $1.50 per hour,
so it's easy for you to get
started for smaller workloads.
And then in July this year,
we also made serverless
easy to use in environments
that have constrained networking.
So Serverless now requires
only three IP addresses
to get started and you can deploy it
with only two availability zones.
It is fully compatible with IPv6.
So if you have regulated
or constrained networking environments,
it's easy for you to get
started with Serverless.
Now, while Redshift Serverless
has seen tremendous growth
since we launched it in 2021,
we heard from a lot of our
large enterprise customers
that had predictable usage.
They were asking us a way to get discounts
and lower their overall cost of Redshift.
So I'm very happy to share
that in April this year,
we launched support for Redshift
Serverless reservations,
where you can commit to a
certain number of RPUs every year
and get up to 24% discount
off of your list price
for Redshift Serverless.
This option is available
in two different flavors.
You can pay all upfront or
you can pay partial upfronts.
What's even better is
that these reservations
are applied at the payer account level
and can be shared across your multiple
different AWS accounts.
Thereby, giving you a lot of flexibility
if you're running a large
enterprise architecture,
where you have different business unit
or different teams that
might want to benefit
from the serverless reservations.
Centralized identity
and unified governance,
we knew as customers continue
to scale the Redshift environment,
centralized identity
and unified governance
are very important.
So I'm very happy to share
that only a few days back,
Redshift launched support
for centralized identity
and unified governance by integrating
with AWS Lake Formation
and AWS Glue Data Catalog.
Now, you can log into any Redshift cluster
using your IAM Identity
Center credentials,
or simply your IAM credentials,
defined fine grain access
control permissions,
like role level security,
column level permissions,
or dynamic data masking,
and have those permissions
apply to any cluster
or any warehouse across your
entire Redshift environment.
With these features,
your users can log into
any Redshift cluster,
define permissions,
and have the confidence
that those permissions
and identities would apply
to any cluster and any warehouse
across your Redshift environment.
Another area of investment for us
as we build out the vision
for distributed warehouse
was concurrency scaling.
Ever since we launched
concurrency scaling in 2019,
customers told us how
much they value the fact
that their Redshift
clusters can automatically
and dynamically scale up
anytime there is a spike
in query volume or demand.
This year, we have enhanced
the concurrency scaling feature
so that all of your
ingestion, transformation,
and consumption workloads can easily burst
across different clusters
using concurrency scaling.
I'm happy to share that very soon,
you will have support for
additional workload types
on concurrency scaling,
such as autocopy from S3,
Zero-ETL, materialized view
creation, spectrum queries,
refreshes of streaming materialized views,
all of these different workloads can scale
across clusters using concurrency scaling.
In fact, these features are
already available to you
in all the regions except IAD,
and we are rolling our support
for IAD very, very soon here.
After which, we will make public
announcements around this.
Related to concurrency scaling,
also happy to share that
in October this year,
we launched support for
DML and DDL commands.
So you can now use create table like
and alter table commands on
concurrency scaling clusters,
which makes it very easy for customers
to do complex table operations
and manage ingestion
pipelines across clusters.
The third big pillar
for Redshift this year
has been around Iceberg Apache support.
We are seeing increasing number
of analytic customers adopt Apache Iceberg
as their open table format
as it provides a high
performance, open source solution
for customers to build their
analytics architecture.
Across AWS, we are fully
behind Apache Iceberg
and we are adding support
for Apache Iceberg
across a variety of different data
and analytics services at AWS.
In Redshift, we have also
added support for Iceberg,
and I'm very happy to
share that Redshift now
has support for Iceberg table rights,
where you can create and
insert Iceberg tables
directly from within Redshift.
And last year, if you remember,
we added support for
Iceberg read capability.
So building up on that,
now Redshift has support
for both Iceberg read
and write capabilities,
giving customers maximum flexibility
to build their analytics
architectures on top of Iceberg.
We have also made a number of enhancements
in terms of improving the performance
of data lake queries from Redshift,
and I'm happy to share
that based on a series
of query optimization techniques,
Redshift now delivers two
times better price performance
on data lake queries that are run
on data lake tables
built on top of Iceberg.
The last thing I'll mention on this
is that we have added
support for auto refresh
of materialized views built
on top of Iceberg data.
The way this feature works
is that it periodically pulls
Iceberg buckets to see,
it pulls S3 buckets to see
if there are any new Iceberg files.
And anytime it detects a new Iceberg file,
it auto triggers a refresh
of materialized views.
The benefit of this is that
U.S. customers get access
to near real time updates,
near real time insights into your data
without having to do this
work manually yourself.
So, so far, we have
discussed why it is important
for customers to have a platform
that has very, very strong
cloud data warehouse fundamentals, right?
We've talked about performance,
we talked about security,
we talked about distributed warehouses,
we talked about global region
availability, et cetera.
But what about the end customer use cases?
So when I look at the landscape
of what customers are
doing with Amazon Redshift,
I see that these use cases
fall into a variety of buckets.
If you look at the left-hand
side of this slide,
Redshift has historically been very strong
on batch analytics.
So when customers want to
run end-of-day sales report
or end-of-quarter
regulatory reporting, right?
Lot of customers are
using Redshift for that
and it's very, very sort of tailored
for that particular use case.
Another strong use case we see
customers using Redshift
for is BI dashboarding,
where they want to visualize
their structured data
inside of BI dashboards,
whether it's AWS QuickSight,
or Tableau, or Looker, or
any BI tool of your choice.
We are also seeing increasing number
of customers use Redshift
for complex decision support
or ad hoc analytics.
This includes things like,
you know, market forecasting,
customer segmentation, you
know, those kind of use cases.
And if you remember all
of the performance
enhancements I talked about
that we focused on this
year are basically geared
towards reducing your latency
for first time queries as
well as repeat queries.
And as we continue to make
improvements in that area,
this use case is gonna
get even more stronger.
Moving on, we also see Redshift
play a very critical role
in data processing workloads
for ETL and ELT pipelines,
where customers want to ingest this data
from their operational databases
directly into Redshift,
and they want to transform this data,
either using AWS Glue or custom
SQL commands within Redshift
or use a third party tool like DBT.
Redshift plays a very critical role
in the entire data processing pipeline.
And all the enhancements
we've made around Zero-ETL
and the distributed warehouse architecture
that I talked about earlier
makes this use case even, even stronger.
And then last use case I'll talk about
is near real-time interactive analytics.
We're seeing increasing number
of customers use Redshift
for this particular use case.
And for this use case, both
your ingestion latency,
as well as query latency,
becomes very important.
And so on the ingestion
side, we have made a lot
of improvements on Zero-ETL.
And as a result, we can
bring the ingestion latency
down to single digit seconds.
And on the query performance front,
we continue to improve query performance
for both first time and
repeat queries, right?
So all of these enhancements
will make this use case
even, even stronger,
and customers can use it
for things like clickstream analytics,
IoT monitoring, et cetera.
Now we have thousands
of enterprise customers
that use Redshift daily
for their business-critical applications.
One of those customers is Twilio
that provides a cloud
communication platform
for you to embed your email, voice,
and video directly into your applications.
To learn more about how
Twilio is using Redshift
to transform billing
and analytics at scale,
please welcome principal software engineer
of Twilio, Sean Mckibben.
(audience applauding)
- Thanks, Imran.
About a year ago, my leadership
on Twilio's commerce platform charged us
with reimagining our billing engine.
The business needed new ways to deal
with challenges of scale and flexibility,
and our finance teams needed
to have analytical views
of our data that were not possible
with our classic architecture.
What came out of this
project helped us modernize
and streamline how we process
analytical customer financial data
to empower the business
to imagine new ways
of delivering our products to customers.
Twilio's billing engine processes billions
of usage events every
day, every text message,
every voice call, every video session
from customers like Toyota, Salesforce,
and Shopify needs to be
accurately priced and billed.
Our legacy billing engine was built
when Twilio was much smaller.
It was laser-focused on operational speed,
ingest an event, price it, and move on.
But that architecture
created two critical gaps.
The first was flexibility.
The business wanted
innovative pricing models,
like package deals,
committed use discounts
with overage pricing.
But our system couldn't adapt
without major re-architecture.
Unwinding pricing misconfigurations
was a multi-day engineering effort,
and backdating a discount
was a bespoke time-consuming process.
The second gap was with analytics.
Finance couldn't answer basic questions,
like what would revenue look like
if we changed this pricing tier?
Our BI teams couldn't build dashboards
showing customer usage trends
without impacting the
production billing system.
The operational system
and the analytical needs
were stepping on each other's toes
and neither served our
business use cases very well.
We needed a distributed
data warehouse architecture
that could handle both
transactional billing integrity
and analytical flexibility.
We evaluated several platforms,
traditional data warehouses,
data lakes with query engines,
even a split architecture
with separate operational
and analytical systems, but
our workload is unusual.
This system generates invoice line items,
so we needed financial grade consistency,
guarantees against duplicate
charges or missing events,
but we also needed analytical speed.
Most data warehouses
optimize for analytics
at the expense of consistency.
Most operational databases
can't handle analytical queries at scale.
Redshift bridges that gap for us
as an operational data warehouse.
We get serializable
transactional isolation,
the strongest consistency
guarantees possible,
while maintaining analytical performance.
That's the unlock.
We can ingest events,
aggregate with transactional correctness,
and serve BI queries all in one system.
Plus, Redshift Serverless gives us this
without infrastructure
overhead, no provisioning,
no capacity planning,
no failover management,
and price performance
scaling gives us this means
that our compute adjusts automatically
as our workload changes.
We pay for usage and not for capacity.
The result is that Redshift
Serverless cost us 75% less
than what our previous system did,
all while processing more data
with stronger consistency guarantees,
and enabling analytics that
were impossible before.
Let's look at the ingestion layer.
Billions of events daily
flow from MSK into Redshift Serverless.
Every usage event across
Twilio's platform lands here.
Two architectural decisions
make this work at scale.
First, serializable transaction
isolation for item potency.
Events can arrive multiple times,
whether it's from network
retries or system resubmissions.
But Redshift's consistency
guarantees ensure
that we only count each event once.
No duplicate charges, no
custom deduplication logic,
the transaction model handles it.
Second, auto refreshing materialized views
for real-time aggregation.
We're not batch processing overnight.
As events land, they're
incrementally aggregated
by customer, product, and day,
and our rating system downstream
gets near real-time data.
We stored over half a trillion
events in Redshift so far,
all de-duplicated and
immediately queryable.
That's the foundation.
Now let me show you how
we built on top of it.
We didn't build just one big cluster.
We built what ended up being
a distributed data warehouse.
Multiple Redshift work groups
sharing data through data shares.
Our AWS folks called this
the golden architecture.
And honestly, once we understood it,
we couldn't imagine building
the system any other way.
So we have multiple work groups,
all working off of the same data set,
ingesting writing billions of events.
The pricing engine is
running transformations
and aggregations on those events.
Analytics is querying the results,
but they're all looking at the same tables
through data shares.
We're not making copies or
ETL-ing data between them.
This gave us workload
isolation and cost visibility.
Heavy analytical queries don't
slow down invoice processing.
When we need to reprocess data,
it doesn't impact dashboards
and we can actually see
what each workload costs.
For a financial system, live
data shares are critical.
Everyone sees the same version
of the data in real time.
So let's talk about
what's actually happening
in that pricing engine work group
because this is where it gets complicated.
How complex are we talking?
Our dbt pipeline manages
over 200 million price points
across Twilio's product catalog.
We're dealing with
multi-tiered volume discounts,
promotional discounts that
stack in specific orders,
multi-product bundles where
one thing affects the pricing
of another, bifurcated taxes.
It's genuinely intricate.
We use dbt Core to break this
down into manageable pieces.
Each pricing rule is a discreet SQL model
and dbt orchestrates how they run.
Redshift paralyzes what it can,
serializes what it needs to,
and dbt manages the
dependency graph between them.
The bonus here is that dbt
auto generates documentation
as the pipeline evolves.
We can actually trace the lineage to see
exactly how an invoice
line item was calculated.
That kind of transparency was impossible
with our old system,
but it's critical for
customer trust and compliance.
And here's what surprised us.
Redshift handled these complex joins
and window functions with
very little optimization.
We budgeted weeks for performance tuning
and barely needed it.
We can recalculate an entire
month of billing in 30 minutes
where our old system
took six hours or more.
Midway through this process,
we hit a bit of a snag.
Our product catalog and
pricing configuration data
lived spread across about seven
or eight Aurora databases,
and we only had the current state
of our configuration stored in them.
The old system just priced everything
with whatever was current
at the time of processing.
That's fine if you only
want to go forward,
but we needed the flexibility
to reprice historical usage
for corrections, promotional
adjustments, contract changes.
To do that accurately, we needed
to know when prices changed
and what they were at any point in time.
Zero-ETL with history mode,
which launched in April of this year,
fixed this for us.
We integrated that with Aurora databases
and got full change history
flowing automatically into Redshift.
Every price update, every
configuration change,
timestamped and captured,
no custom CDC to manage.
The result is that we
can reconstruct any bill
from any point in time,
we can reprice historical
usage with exact configuration
that should have applied, or
we can model what invoices
would look like under different scenarios.
That's only possible with
complete change history.
Let's talk about outcomes,
starting with cost.
We're running at a 75% lower
cost than the previous system
while processing more data
with stronger guarantees.
Four people on my team are managing
almost a hundred billion events a month.
Speed.
Six hours down to 30 minutes
for full month recalculations.
Finance dashboards went
from daily batch updates
to sub minute response times.
But the real win is flexibility.
We can now do retroactive pricing changes,
accurately recalculate last month's usage
with today's promotional rules,
product managers can model
new pricing strategies
against real-time usage,
answering questions,
like what if we change this
pricing tier structure?
Billing ops can audit any invoice
and see the complete
calculation lineage in minutes.
We're also auto generating
new data products,
like an effective pricing
model that represents
what any customer will pay
for any product at any time.
Direct rights to S3 and
soon to Iceberg tables
eliminate Spark ETL jobs
for data lake delivery.
The previous system served us well,
but it wasn't built for this
kind of scale or flexibility.
This architecture fundamentally changed
what's possible for the business.
The power of this architecture
is that it doesn't end
with the billing engine.
We're about to start writing
our curated financial data sets
to Iceberg tables, indexed
with AWS Glue Data Catalog.
This opens up the data to
broader organizational use
without having to give everyone
direct access to Redshift,
which brings me to the next
part of our data story.
Teams at Twilio have built
what we call the Odin system,
a query infrastructure layer
on top of these Iceberg tables
and the Glue Data Catalog using Athena.
Scott's gonna walk you through
how you can leverage
Athena's latest features
to democratize data access
across your organization.
Scott?
- Hey, man, thanks.
- Good luck, man.
Appreciate it, oops, sorry.
All right, thank you, Sean.
Thanks again, Sean.
Really loved to hear the
outcomes that Twilio has had,
especially the 75% cost savings,
which is really impressive
at Twilio's scale.
So as Imran mentioned, I'm Scott.
I lead the product management function
for the Athena Service.
Delighted to be with you today.
Like many of you, I'm a data nerd
and I love working with data,
so I wanted to gather
some data from you all.
So raise your hand if this
is your first re:Invent.
All right, cool.
And raise your hand if this is your first
What's New in Athena session?
All right, great to see
some friendly new faces
and previous ones alike.
So as a refresher,
Athena is our serverless
interactive query service that's designed
to make it dead simple to
run SQL on your data lakes.
Customers love Athena's ease of use.
We talk about it often.
It's kind of what we really focus on
on the product team in
every feature that we build.
There's no infrastructure
to set up or manage.
It just works with the
tools that you have today.
Customers love how Athena's
optimized for interactivity.
Meaning, you get queries that
started in under a second
and a fast engine on top
of great out-of-the-box performance.
Last but not least, our engine just works
with the data that you have.
So you can bring your
Parquet, JSON, Iceberg, CSV,
and other data and bring that to Athena,
and start querying right away.
And best yet, we're able to pair
Athena's query engine capabilities
with really deep fine
grain access capabilities
through our lake formation sister service.
So we launched in 2016, and today,
we have customers from every industry,
from startups to large enterprises,
who are running lots of queries per week.
In fact, over billions of queries a week
in our most recent kind
of, you know, metrics.
And so customers are kind
of getting a lot of insights
and value out of their S3 data lake.
So let's talk about the
customer journey with Athena
and how that often starts with Amazon S3.
So customers choose S3 for
its unmatched durability,
scalability, and availability.
Because of those foundational capabilities
and unique differentiators,
customers have been able to build millions
of data lakes on top of S3.
But as Imran mentioned earlier,
there's a big shift
happening in data lakes
and that's open table formats.
Folks love how these open table formats
brings familiar SQL functionality
to kind of where we're all working today,
which is in our S3 based data lake stores.
Athena actually launched its
open table format support
back in 2021, and since then,
we've seen Iceberg emerge
as a leading choice
amongst the open table
formats that we support.
Iceberg is unique amongst
OTFs for its ability
to handle massive scale data sets
while maintaining simplicity,
supporting multiple query
engines like Athena and Spark,
and providing you transactional features
that allow you to write into
your data lakes with ease.
And it does that all without locking you
into a single vendor ecosystem.
So excited to share today
that Athena, this year,
is 1.5 times faster on
Iceberg with Parquet,
based on TIP CDS one terabyte compared
to this time last year.
And we've been able to achieve that
through a number of changes,
starting with our engine,
but kind of kind of cascading out
to our catalog experiences as well.
But wanted to touch on a few of those.
The first is Iceberg Statistics,
which is an existing feature of Athena,
but two weeks ago, we
launched a new update,
where we've actually enhanced the behavior
of the Athena service when it interacts
with statistics files to
ultimately make queries run faster.
So to use Iceberg Statistics,
basically what you'll do
is you'll fire up AWS Glue
and ask Glue to collect
statistics on your Iceberg tables.
And then when you come to Athena
and you query those tables,
Athena will automatically
apply the statistics
to make more intelligent
query planning decisions.
So automatically accelerating your queries
without a ton of work to do.
So it's a great feature.
And so, that's an awesome
feature we launched
just a couple weeks ago
is an updated experience
for Iceberg Stats.
We also launched a net new
feature, Parquet column indexing,
which allows queries to skip
irrelevant blocks of data,
which reduces unnecessary IOL operations
when reading from S3.
So this is like really
beneficial, especially on queries
that have selective filter
predicates on sorted data.
So that's fairly common in, you know,
a lot of enterprise reporting scenarios
is to have sorted data.
So great feature to try out.
And for our customers who are
using lake formation today
to secure their and govern
their Iceberg tables,
just a couple weeks ago,
we announced new partition
pruning behaviors
for lake formation tables with
row filters and column masks,
and additional predicate
push down behaviors,
which altogether will help
improve query performance,
reduce cost, and does that
without sacrificing data governance.
So on Sunday, we launched
a new feature for Iceberg,
which is called materialized views.
This is a really cool feature.
This is essentially a
managed Iceberg table
that stores pre-computed
query results for you,
and then always ready to query S3 Table
that you can or Iceberg
table that you can query
through Athena and other engines.
Super easy to use, they're
automatically updated
when source data changes.
So your kind of data is flowing
through materialized views,
and again, always
available for you to query.
So you're always seeing
the latest and greatest.
And it does all of that
without any infrastructure to manage.
So today, we support
read support on Athena,
but you can also go out to
Redshift, Spark on EMR, and Glue,
and perform additional
operations over there.
What we like to talk about with this one
is like what are some good use cases
for materialized views with Athena?
And a lot of customers come to Athena
and sort of build these
decomposed SQL pipelines
on top of this service.
So imagine if you have a complex
data transformation pipeline
today that's joining
and manipulating a
bunch of tables together
to produce one single output table,
that's now something
you can kind of reflect
as a materialized view
in Glue Data Catalog
and express that as SQL,
and get the always updated benefits
that we now provide
through materialized views.
So really easy to get started
with this one as well.
You'll fire up one of our Spark
experiences in EMR or Glue,
or use those Glue APIs to launch
or create your materialized view.
And when you're creating
one, you'll get to choose
whether you store your materialized view
in a self-managed Iceberg table
or an Amazon S3 Table,
which is a great segue
to all the good work we've
been doing with S3 Tables.
So if you remember back
to this time last year
at re:Invent, we talked about
and announced preview for Amazon S3 Tables
as the first fully managed
Iceberg offering in the cloud.
S3 Tables is really great
because it simplifies the tedious stuff
of running a Iceberg data lake.
Things like table compaction
and expiring old snapshots,
S3 tables handles all of that for you.
So this year, we've been really busy
taking S3 tables to GA,
which we did on Pi Day in March.
And in that launch, we added
expanded DDL operations.
So gave you create database
and create table operators,
plus a bunch of others.
That made it possible
to work with S3 Tables
end-to-end through Athena SQL.
So really excited about what
that allows customers to do.
And in that launch, we also
added a new console wizard
to help you get started quickly.
In August, we launched
Create Tables as Select,
which is a very popular feature in Athena.
We call it CTAS.
What CTAs lets you do is convert data
from one format to another.
And so it's a really
no-brainer feature to have
with S3 Tables.
So imagine what you can do with this one,
is just to give you an example use case.
Let's assume you have an application
that's writing JSON data out to S3
and you want to query that JSON data,
but you need a columnar level performance
to meet the latency
requirements of your use case.
What you can now do is a
CTAS on that JSON data,
convert that into an S3 Table,
and then tomorrow when new records show up
from your JSON data stream,
you can run an insert
operation on top of that table
to bring your new records
over to your S3 Table,
and drive your queries off of the S3 Table
instead of your JSON data.
So that's a really cool feature.
So in kind of the back half of the year,
what we've been doing
is optimizing the rest
of the S3 Tables experience.
And what's really great
about how we're working
with the S3 team and the
work we're doing over there
is that all of the
features that I mentioned
for Iceberg on the previous slides,
you also get with S3 Tables.
So Parquet column indexing,
updated statistics,
all of that good stuff
applies to S3 Tables,
but you're also getting
the performance features
that our partner teams and
S3 and Glue Data Catalog
have also been delivering,
like Z order and sort compaction,
plus a bunch of operational tweaks
that they've been
delivering to reduce latency
across the experience.
So now we recognize that Iceberg
is not the only data format out there.
And when we look at
the data that customers
are querying today, we see lots of JSON,
we see lots of text, CSV,
and other data formats,
and we're proud to share that the majority
of those queries are quite fast indeed,
completing in under two seconds.
We're able to achieve this
through how Athena's engine
is designed and tuned,
but also because of how Athena provides
the serverless compute infrastructure
that automatically scales
based on query complexity
and is able to run multiple
queries in parallel.
So this year, as we kind
of looked at this data,
we asked, you know,
howelse can we accelerate
or bring the performance bar higher
for some of these additional data formats
that customers are querying today?
And that took us down a
pretty interesting path
of actually redesigning our file system,
and our readers and writers for a bunch
of different file formats
to bring faster experience
when interacting with those
files through the Athena engine.
So we're seeing some really
awesome results there
as this slide highlights.
And just to highlight a few,
Parquet, as I mentioned,
is a super popular format,
is now 1.2 times faster
when used with Hive.
Then this time last year, JSON, 2x faster.
CSV, yeah, folks are
still passing CSVs around.
I'm definitely guilty of that.
It's now 1.8x faster
compared to last year.
And then Iceberg, we talked
a little bit about already,
but Delta Lake is seeing a
good boost this year as well.
So when we talk about these
features kind of rolling out,
normally, what you kind of hear is,
well, now I have to
upgrade to this new thing,
and that's a lot of work.
But where we try to do
things differently on Athena
is kind of work ahead of you
and figure out better ways
to migrate our customers
and bring them along for these journeys.
So what we've been doing with this rollout
is over the course of this year,
we've been moving customers automatically
to these new formats
and our new file system
based on compatibility checks
that we've run in the background.
So chances are you're already
getting these benefits
or you'll be getting these very soon
in your production applications.
So I'm really excited about that.
Now we've also been shipping
performance features
kind of elsewhere in the service,
so I wanted to highlight a
few of those today as well.
Query result reuse or what we call QRR
is a caching feature that Athena has.
What's really neat about this
is it can bypass query execution
under certain conditions.
And what means in that case
is you're bypassing the actual latency
from the query engine itself,
but you're also getting a
query that ran in, you know,
sub-hundred milliseconds
as you're sort of bypassing the execution
and picking up the previous query results.
So here, we actually changed
how our hashing function works
to ignore small variations
in how different people write queries.
So a good example is code comments
or use of white space
characters in your queries.
And we've done all of
that to actually increase
the cache hit ratio when you're
using query result reuse.
So that's a really sweet
feature to turn on.
You just toggle a switch
within the Athena console
or our APIs to activate it,
and if a result is found,
Athena will again bypass execution
and give you the previous matching result.
We also rewrote some of our memory logic
way down in the engine with
the goal of reducing failures
and making queries that have heavy shuffle
and joint operators more stable at scale.
So what we've done there is, again,
kind of tweak a lot of the
very deep kind of behaviors
of the engine internals to
get better memory stability
and efficiency out of the engine.
So you should get fewer
failures on queries
that have a lot of process
a lot of data in memory.
So we'll switch gears a little bit
and talk about some
administrator features.
One of those is capacity reservations.
This is not too different
from Redshift Serverless reservations,
and this is Athena's feature
for guaranteed serverless compute
on top of our kind of managed
compute infrastructure.
It's really ideal for mission
critical applications,
dashboards, any SLA-sensitive
reporting jobs you may have,
as well as user-facing applications
that have a requirement for
significant concurrency.
To use it, pretty straightforward,
you create a reservation
and then you choose a number
of compute units, which
would be called DPUs.
And then you assign this
reservation to your work groups,
which allows your
reservation to share capacity
across your work groups.
And what's really great
about how this feature works
is there's no SQL changes needed.
You basically just configured
this setup here on the screen
and Athena automatically knows what to do
and routes queries from those work groups
to your reserved capacity units.
So last week, we
announced two new features
for capacity reservations.
The first is capacity and cost controls.
This is a new setting that influences
how Athena assigns data processing units
or DPUs to each of your queries.
You can set it at the work group level.
That gives you a centralized
kind of way to apply defaults,
kind of min and max range
for each of your queries.
But you can also control DPU
allocation at the query level
through new features in our
start query execution API
that now now allowed
this property to be set.
And that gives you precise
task level performance control
that customers who've used
our preview of this feature
have been able to get very low latency
out of their queries
through experimentation
and get very high levels of utilization
on their reserved capacity.
So really great feature.
Last but not least on that one
is we now have new observability data
in our get query results API.
So after you run a query
on capacity reservation,
we now tell you exactly how
many DPU it would consume.
So you can use that new
data to help you plan
for maybe future queries
that have a similar shape
and may have a difference
or a slightly different capacity need.
So we also launched an
auto scaling solution.
This is really neat.
This works as a step
function state machine.
So it's completely serverless
and it's entire logic is
kind of presented to you
as the state machine.
So you can go into the
step functions console
and kind of explore and
look at how it works.
But that also means it's highly open
and flexible to customization
for different requirements
that you may have.
The way it works is it basically monitors
the utilization of a reservation
and it'll make capacity adjustments based
on the parameters that
you set for look back
and how frequently and by
how much you should scale
based on your workload.
To launch it or to get started,
you have a console click-through
button that we've provided,
as well as documentation
that provides you a link
into the cloud formation experience.
Managed query results
is another admin feature
that we launched earlier this year.
This is a really great feature
if you're an administrator out there
because it simplifies your experience
by allowing the Athena service
to automatically store query
results in our own storage
rather than your S3 bucket.
So we're kind of taking over the headache
of having to manage query
result files for you.
And what's neat about this
is we store results for a day
at no cost to you and
automatically expire them
and delete them after that one-day period
with no action needed on your part.
So no longer you need to take action
to manage query's old
files or their lifecycle.
And what we also did with this feature
is we actually elevated the permissions
for query results to
be tied to work groups
instead of an S3 bucket.
So it should simplify permissions
for folks who are accessing Athena
through different work groups.
So it's been a really
busy year of launches
and we couldn't get to everything today,
but we wanted to make sure
there's some key launches
that you had kind of
at least visibility on
to check out while
you're here at re:Invent.
The first is Amazon SageMaker notebooks.
I don't know if you've seen the keynotes
or some of the other
announcements on this one.
This is a really cool feature.
I'm glad we had a chance
to talk about it today.
This is a brand new native notebook UI
in SageMaker Unified Studio.
It's integrated with Athena
SQL and Athena Spark Engines,
and deliver it to you as a single canvas,
providing you a data analysis
and development experience in one spot.
It's also multi-dialect.
So in one cell, you can
run a SQL query on Athena,
then you can run some Python code,
then you can run some Spark
code, all in one canvas,
with data frame access kind
of in between each cell.
So you kind of work with data in memory
and in a really snappy experience.
So it's really cool.
Best yet is you can work
alongside our data agents,
which is a built-in AI agent
that helps you do data analysis.
So it's a really great feature
if you're getting started
to learn some new data set
and want to extract some insights from it,
you can kind of task data agent
with helping you with some of that work.
And kind of behind the
scenes here, underneath,
we've upgraded the Athena
Spark engine to a 3.5.6,
and we've also given Spark Connect support
and Spark Live UI support to
the Athena Spark experience.
SMUS, as I mentioned,
SageMaker Unified Studio,
we've kind of continued on
the notebook experience.
We've also added a one-click onboarding
with IAM permission experience,
brought new AI power
column and metadata rules
and many other features
on our unified studio.
So if you get a chance to,
while you're here at re:Invent,
drop by some of the SageMaker sessions
to see what that's all about.
At re:Invent this year, you'll
probably also hear a lot
about trusted identity
propagation, also known as TIP.
This gets you a way to
authenticate end users
based on their corporate identities,
and have that identity propagate
to all of the AWS services
that they're using
when they're querying and analyzing data.
So that's Athena, S3, Glue, Lambda, KMS,
all the services that Athena will talk to
and querying your data.
And that gives you end-to-end auditability
on user actions tied to identity.
It also plugs into lake formation.
So you can define fine
grade access controls
based on corporate identity
and have those enforced
by engines like Athena and Spark.
And from a Redshift
and Athena perspective,
we've also carried TIP
support out to our drivers.
So if you're logging in
through third party
clients, like DataGrip,
you now have a browser-based
authentication flows
that use TIP to, again, authenticate
with your corporate identity.
And on MCP, you know a
growing number of customers
are developing AI agents,
and doing new and interesting
things with agents
to perform different tasks.
So we launched earlier this
year, several MCP servers,
Redshift, Athena, EMR, and
Glue just to name a few.
And we're seeing customers
build really cool things
on top of that.
For example, you know,
building agents to query
and analyze and extract insights
from your data lakes all autonomously.
So really cool progress on MCP.
So as we wrap up, if you wanna learn more
about what we shared today,
definitely scan these QR
codes, get your phones out.
A lot of really awesome blogs here.
One on Redshift Serverless
reservations and Iceberg Rights.
You should definitely check out.
There's one on data transformation
with Athena and S3 Tables.
So as you think
about that Create Table
as Select experience
we talked about earlier,
that's a great blog to check out
with a lot of practical takeaways.
And we've also included
the Odin deep dive deck.
So our folks at Twilio and
our customers at Twilio,
who've built and support
the Odin platform,
they've got a really neat blog
that describes their journey
and building that on top of
Athena, which we recommend.
And then we hope that you've, you know,
taken the learnings like from
our session today further
and that you can kind of leverage other,
you know, learning and
knowledge capabilities
and resources that we have here at AWS.
For that, we have AWS Skill Builder,
tons of great resources for you to learn,
practice, and get AWS-certified.
So definitely check that out
and share that with your teammates.
And so that about wraps
up the 206 session,
What's New in Redshift and Athena.
Definitely on behalf of the AWS team,
I wanna send a thank you to Sean at Twilio
for sharing his journey with us,
and Imran for sharing the insights
on the exciting Redshift launches.
So last but not least,
thank you for attending
and spending the hour with us today.
We'd love to hear your feedback,
so pop into the events app
and give us your rating,
and have a great rest of the re:Invent.
Thanks.
(audience applauds)